[Applause]
very interesting things have happened
this week in the in the athletic world
did Akash is gonna help break down but
remember last week we were all like how
what the [ __ ] is going on with Tom Brady
why is he going to the Buccaneers yeah
you know we had our fears etc well this
week report was dropped and it basically
explained the saga leading up to now so
it explains it's an ESPN article it's a
pretty long read yeah the long and short
of it is everybody that kind of cents
this for the past five years and has
been whispering I don't think Tom
Brady's happy I'm happy
they were right he kind of started to go
away from the Belichick method and
leaned into his own tv12 thing what is
that you know the tv12 method about
pliability and he had his trainer and
there was this article it came out like
two years ago where he would have his
trainer in the facility a bunch Guerrero
sir Alexis Guerrero said he was his name
and people's about our friend oh maybe
he's Alex Caruso cool against what's up
but he he had a trainer that he would
bring in that was his T b12 guy and then
it kind of started to cause a division
in the locker room Bella checks and I'm
home there was some tension there Brady
essentially long and short didn't feel
appreciated he felt like I don't like
that Belichick is just kind of like
undermining he treats me like every
other player essentially oh he wanted to
be treated me yeah he's not even trying
to undermine you like hey if you're good
just let you know you're not as good as
you think of its the second you're not
of use to me we will get rid of you his
dad had a quote that was something like
the second they find a quarterback as
good as Brady for a dollar cheaper
they're done with Brady and that's the
kind of yeah Brady's dad said something
like that and Brady kind of felt the
same way and like he felt like a Widow's
deflategate everybody just had him take
the [ __ ] fall Belichick wasn't really
with him standing by him in the news
conference whatever like all these
little things added up were bright he's
like yo these guys don't appreciate me
and he was just unhappy or and unhappy
or overtime he wanted a longer-term deal
like now in his last couple of contracts
extensions and all that and Belichick
was just like my own saving
just from reading a little excerpts of
it was that she didn't ask for the
long-term deal but he was specifically
going for the one-year deals to have
like leverage in the offseason
my understanding and I would have to
reread it now because maybe I
misunderstood but my understanding was
he wanted to retire a patriot but they
wouldn't really commit to him till he
was 45 which is how long he wants to
play and that was just like yo you don't
think I'm gonna do it you don't
appreciate what I've done I'm I'm down
to retire a patriot but then it just got
as they would have like two year deals
with little opt outs or whatever but it
was always the idea that we're not fully
committing to you we're ready to move on
and we need to essentially and Brady had
a certain point guy he just he's so
[ __ ] like upset at Belichick
well there's one big moment go ahead III
my big moment is it happened prior to
the Garoppolo trade so you know in Jimmy
Garoppolo got traded to the 49ers right
you remember in this Alex yeah every day
at home I'm sure you guys remember Jimmy
Garoppolo yeah there was a lot of
tension between Belichick and Brady
right and you know Belichick was and
well Brady was basically like you know
what's the deal what's going on here I
think Brady was coming off of injury no
that's coming off a deflategate
Garoppolo played that year injury was
like 2008 2007 something like that matt
cassel started a you're the one okay so
maybe placate but there's three
quarterbacks that they had they were all
saw quarterbacks it was Jacoby they're
all started now you know there is Jimmy
Garoppolo yeah and the whole league they
traded I think Jacoby or they let Jacoby
go to the Colts Yeah right and then
Jimmy Garoppolo was like everybody the
league's are you know this is starting
quarterback this before obviously the
49ers where we show that he might be
limited everybody was really excited
about him he's a number one and I guess
he was playing some games he was [ __ ]
balling his ass off ballin and Belichick
really liked him and Belichick preferred
him to Brady and Brady was not [ __ ]
having it Brady was upset and Brady kind
of put his foot down it was like hey
listen you're not gonna have this other
quarterback here I'm the quarterback of
the team and Belichick calls up the
49ers to make a trade and offers Brady
to the 49ers
I'm not read this part no I didn't si
that's the big thing so he calls up the
49ers and offers Brady
before 9:00 is like what yeah are you
serious
Kraft gets wind of it shuts it down
right I had heard that was that dead but
that was the so when he was like make a
decision and the decision is me right
fellow tech was like no it's not yeah
and then offers Brady the [ __ ] 49ers
and Kraft has to stop it and the 49ers
gym or whoever the [ __ ] was on the other
line was like where did I hear this
right they got at least one if not two
Super Bowls after that - they went to it
yeah they went to - yeah so they got at
least they won at least one they gone to
- they might have had the fifth you
might he got his fifth ring after
deflategate I'm not completely positive
but so Belichick would have been wrong
they're my kind of view on it with Brady
is like what do you think got you the
dynasty bill doing this why would you
think it's gonna stop for you it's good
and ugly because you have an ego and he
has an ego and I see emotionally how you
hurt but in the back of your mind you
gotta know oh this is great you know
when you [ __ ] up and you're upset I was
here Friday we're talking out some [ __ ]
my car got towed and I'm upset do you
why the [ __ ] is New York City towing
you're giving a reprieve for all these
people blah blah blah why you still
telling me I know in the back of my mind
this is my fault this is what it is I
know the deal the truth Tom Brady got it
on the bag his mind is this is what got
you the dynasty
Bill Belichick doesn't love anyone he's
not gonna love you when the time comes
and that is a tough pill to swallow but
it got you a [ __ ] dynasty
the greatest dynasty ever and it might
not have been that without you poll
accept that but just you that's Peyton
Manning just a great quarterback
that's Peyton Manning Peyton Manning
having all his offensive weapons
throwing these touchdowns two Super
Bowls and one of them he got [ __ ]
carried to when he was washed
that's the Broncos that's the Broncos oh
my god man that's an amazing point you
can't be upset about the Patriot way if
you benefited from
patriot way yeah this is some patriot
way yes and that's a Tom Brady way it's
not t be 12
that's what Belichick is probably
thinking he's like wait why why are you
getting your [ __ ] panties in a bunch
about this we had to sit down every year
where I said I was gonna I was gonna
release these players and I was gonna
get rid of these plays and trade these
players and you were totally okay with
it and on board with and even if they
didn't have a sit-down you knew and you
saw and you're smart and you won and I
love Tom Brady and I hope he wins a ring
with Tampa Bay but like this is what it
is man you gotta know this is what it
was gonna be it had to end like this
and I think with time they'll be okay
cuz you'll realize that right now it's
super [ __ ] he's in the ceilings and
the bag is mine he got a no dude you
know what that really makes me I really
make spellcheck more likeable it's like
everybody asks for quality right
everybody asks to be treated equal
everybody begs for that right and then
it's right up his alley or hey yeah I
know likeable to you because you know
what it is like we all ask for that
right we all ask for certain treatment
but we don't know what that treatment
entails right like we tease women all
the time on the podcast like y'all ask
for equality but when it benefits you
and then what it doesn't you're like now
I'm good
right we're just talking about right now
yeah and that's the situation with Tom
Brady right it's like you asked for well
maybe he never asked for quite maybe he
wants to be treated better but everybody
in the world asked for this concept of
equality and then when we have an
actually equal system truly equal hey I
don't care who the [ __ ] you are Tom
Brady or whatever it takes to win
whatever whatever your [ __ ] name is
whatever it takes when that means we cut
Tom Brady a year before he's done and we
cut the guy that you don't even know a
year before he said this is just the
Patriot way and everybody falls in line
I can sleep at night as Belichick with
that yeah and if you spell that out to
your players and I don't even know if
you owe them that but if it's known in
the ethos it's known in the culture they
shouldn't be that upset about it there
yeah it's your job to play like you have
two more years left cuz if you play like
you got one you're gone yeah so keep
that and you know what that might have
been the thing that allowed Tom Brady to
play in an easily
level until he's 42 years old because
he's always been playing like he got two
more left oh that's interesting
and hey maybe they'd have been that
maybe they had a one for ten years
longer if they traded Garoppolo whatever
cuz like he had in his mind he's
quarterback of the future who's young so
I could get I could get the world for
Tom Brady right now and then built
around this guy who was in his early 20s
and just move forward and now we got 15
more years
dude that's a great deal I would I not
do this and I love Brady do I'm a Brady
fan yes but like that's that is the
patriot way that is what we all [ __ ]
put them on a pedestal for that's what
you benefit really surprised though
because if the Patriot Way is like that
as a player how how do you give your all
I know you give your all to stay on but
then it's like why would you want to be
on a team that you know like hey if I
start to slip I'm out of here it's like
you kind of want a little bit of that
security like yo you know if something
happens to me my team got me or you know
my squad got me so Belichick doesn't
they don't win a ton in like the free
agency game they don't often go out
there and throw money at the best free
agent and get a bunch of players they'll
draft you guys who Julian Edelman was
nobody gave a [ __ ] about Julian Edelman
was actually it was a Dallas news Dallas
Morning News writer who was like a
sports guy who was cool with Belichick
and he's like got a hard-on for special
teams and he's like hey Bill and Bill
loves special teams like Bill this guy's
a good special teams player yeah that's
how Bill got he gets castoffs
so special teams for everybody anybody
who's foreign it doesn't watch American
football that's a punt return kickoff
return and yeah
kicking off it cetera yeah it is I don't
understand how there's like people that
love special tip why that affects the
game so much why it's so important I
don't really take is obsessed with it so
it's gotta mean something in my mind but
[Music]
it's the old position and then the field
goal you know if you get two extra
points a game that can win you one
that'll swing one or two games a season
so the Cowboys lost the Cowboys had a
terrible kicker all year's name was Bill
Maher he missed like 50% of his field
goals which is a terrible percentage you
should be somewhere on 7080 right that's
like three points a game they
like four or five games by three points
so if theoretically now you're not gonna
make a hundred percent but if you went a
hundred percent and you get next to
three points a game or whatever it is
now you're twelve and four instead a an
eight and now you're one of the best
records in the league and setup not it's
like a free-throw shooting its
free-throw shooting it is that exact you
know seventy-five percent or something
like that yeah there's no close games
that you don't win yeah yeah so it's
like that interesting okay and fuel
position matters and you know getting a
ball at your field position thing is
interesting like if you could really
maximize field position and football
especially if you're a team that has a
great defense and this is another thing
about what makes Bill Belichick so smart
I don't think he's still doing it but
he's just always experimenting the NFL
the kickoffs people get hurt very badly
on kickoffs I don't know why it's
something about kickoffs over punts
people that career-ending injuries
happen paralysis happens the most when
people will get paralyzed on the field
during kickoffs so the NFL is kind of
trying to phase them out so they moved
the kickoff from the 30-yard line to 35
so it'd be more to touch back he's
kicking in the endzone take it to the
25-yard line
yeah Belichick instead of kicking it in
the end zone told his kickers kick it as
high as you can we have more time so we
have more time to get down there and if
a touchback is gonna give you to the 25
if you kneel in the endzone
let's see if we can tag him with the 20
18 19 21 22 let's just get that extra 5
yards like that's the guy's a [ __ ]
maniac
so to expect any emotion out of this guy
I just don't see how you can do that
yeah and he doesn't like yeah he's not
Randy Randy Moss weren't there when
Randy Moss we got traded to Oakland and
then kind of wasn't doing anything and
was just struggling so now we make a
trade for Randy Moss yeah but you answer
my question it's like they tend to get
players who just are happy to play yeah
it's not a lot of guys be on a team not
a lot of young 20-something guys who are
in line for their first huge paycheck or
even ever going to the Patriots it's a
rare spot there he's like oh yeah he's a
tiger King he finds he finds players
that are extremely needy right they're
down and out they have no other option
with you know he takes them
yeah and they'll do anything he wants
because Julian Edelman wasn't getting
all these other opportunities from other
teams Yeah right it was nothing it was
like you don't get to play football at
all I'm playing the NFL come you won't
come over here yeah and then you could
treat them however they want because
they are but I already have it in their
head hey I'm disposable so when you
dispose of them they're like that's
what's supposed to happen we're gonna
talk about this one to the tiger King
when Marcos is a SUP but yeah the thing
about me maybe here already I just huh
we might be holding him off for you know
when you this will be again we'll talk
about it might not be mark that we have
it coming in might be some enough [ __ ]
ya never know
when our of a new Netflix show I mean
you never recurrent Netflix documentary
you never know about these things on the
you know flavor to pocket
[Applause]
[Music]